Kendall Jenner and Bad Bunny packing on
the PDA oh my God just be cool it's fine
it looks more than fine sparks flying
between the model and the singer in
these new images which seemingly confirm
they're some sort of item that's Kendall
and Bad Bunny walking out of a sushi
restaurant in La before the pair went
their separate ways they hugged and at
one point kissed the lip lock isn't
visible but Kenny wrapped her arms
around his neck in what looks to be a
cozy goodbye
foreign
[Music]
the two weren't alone on their outing
yeah Kendall's sister Kylie also joined
them for dinner along with other friends
and a ton of security of course I love
it Kendall and Bad Bunny started fueling
dating Rumors in February following a
hangout with Justin and Haley Bieber A
source told E.T at the time they're
attracted to each other and definitely
have a flirty Vibe quote it's still new
but they're enjoying each other's
company and like each other it's not
always easy but I don't know I just kind
of I like to keep my private life pretty
private so
um I try my best but at the same time I
don't I don't like to let being seen out
in public with someone like affect my
everyday life so how did this pairing
come to be well another source told E.T
Kendall met Bad Bunny real name Benito
Ocasio through a mutual friend and they
hit it off but as of now it's not
serious and the two are having fun it's
really exciting both Bad Bunny and
Kendall are coming out of long-term
relationships the Grammy winner had been
dating Gabriella burlingary on and off
since 2017.
[Music]
while Kendall was with NBA star Devin
Booker the two broke up twice last year
it's not always easy and as far as if
fans will see Kenny's rumor new romance
on season three of the Kardashians it
seems like a long shot just from a
really young age I think both Kylie and
I kind of knew what we wanted to keep
off the show or what we wanted to keep
to ourselves and um yeah I think that
it's kind of as simple as that and you
know we learn and again our boundaries
may change one day depending on the
situation
[Music]
thank you